[Musique]
cette semaine en quête le mont everest
cimetière d'alpinistes sans expérience
on avait l'impression non pas de gravir
une montagne mais de voir une scène
d'horreur après l'autre l'histoire
horrible d'une canadienne novès en
alpinisme qui rêvait d'atteindre le
sommet du monde
il est 9h30 heure locale nous sommes au
camp de base juste au pied du mont
everest
on va l'escaladé dans moins d'un mois
[Musique]
une détermination étonnante au dessus
mais complètement stupide sans direction
ni personne pour lui dire de revenir
s'est retrouvé coincé dans une compagnie
qui avait pas d'expérience
un orque season je les appelais quatre
fois président ne m'a pas répondu je ne
me laisse pas signer
[Musique]
bienvenue au club autrefois atteindre le
sommet de l'everest relever de l'exploit
rares étaient ceux et celles qui
pouvaient réaliser l'ascension de la
plus haute montagne du monde de près de
9000 mètres d'altitude
mais aujourd'hui l'everest est presque
devenu une attraction commerciale pour
touristes extrême
il existe de plus en plus de compagnies
offrant le service de guide qui organise
des expéditions d'alpinistes sur
l'everest
on en finit par oublier que ça demeure
une aventure extrêmement dangereuse
seulement ce printemps dix personnes y
ont perdu la vie nous vous présentons
cette semaine histoire dramatique d'une
femme de toronto
prête à tout pour réussir cet exploit y
compris mettre sa vie en péril
comme vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage adapté du fait tester de la
sib ici les choses ont malheureusement
mal tourné pour elle
[Musique]
il est presque impossible de saisir ce
qu'il everest
aussi haut que la trajectoire de vol des
jets intercontinentaux glacial comme
l'arctique
il y à peine assez d'oxygène pour
maintenir la vie
et si meurtrier que des centaines de
personnes sont mortes en tentant
d'atteindre le chemin d'en redescendre
malgré tout cela il continue d'exercer
une attraction atteindre je me souviens
de la vie le soleil était assez bas et
je pouvais encore voir le sommet du mont
everest une vue à couper le souffle
[Musique]
la première fois que free yasha à voile
everest et les enfants et vit au népal
si je me disais un jour je crie cela
plusieurs décennies plus tard à toronto
où elle vit elle annonce à son ami
virginia novak quart 33 ans elle va
raviver ce rêve elle m'a dit je vais
escalader l'everest et je lui ai répondu
ah tu perds tu la tête et elle a dit non
j'ai toujours voulu le faire pour
vulcania novak fria est une véritable
force de la nature ou le fais rien 3 y
est on est la même c'était une femme
très sûre d'elle et cette confiance en
elle là ni mais c'était une personne
très motivés né à l'ombre du mont
everest chouïa parcourt le monde
elle travaille pour une entreprise de
croisière c'est ainsi qu'elle rencontre
le canadien gauche trop fine le pianiste
du navire il la trouve irrésistible
shehada je peux vous dire qu'une
certaine douceur émanait d'elle
c'est ce qu'il dégageait quand j'ai eu
assez de courage pour l'approcher je me
suis dit qu'il y avait quelque chose
dans son attitude qui était très
plaisant
il tombe amoureux
une fois mariée et s'établissent au
canada à toronto je suis à fond d'une
entreprise d'importation de mets indiens
et des pistes elle fait de la politique
candidat d'un parti marginal à la
dernière élection provinciale en ontario
elle n'obtient que quelques centaines de
votes tout ce que sa femme faisait
c'était avec passion nous dit poudre
fine quand elle voulait quelque chose
rien ne pouvait l'arrêter mais il est
aussi surpris que tous les autres quand
elle annonce qu'elle veut escalader
l'everest
chedjou elle a juste dit je vais me
rendre au sommet du mont everest
c'était complètement inattendu mais
après qu'il m'ait parlé de son projet je
n'ai pas pu l'en dissuader et croyez moi
j'ai essayé
virginia novak ne peut pas la raisonner
et non plus comme à son habitude elle
m'a répondu tu es une merde pour le jeu
ne t'en fais pas tout va bien aller et à
mon retour on va arroser ça d'accord et
ça s'arrête là
il reste moins d'un an avant l'escaladé
prévue en mai 2012 pour se préparer et
fria fait des randonnées pas en montagne
mais dans la campagne ontarienne
elle s'entraîne dans une salle d'
escalade et gravi l'escalier des 40
étages de son immeuble de toronto en
portant un sac à dos lester pour
financer son expédition shaiya loue du
matériel d'escaladé et grâce à un
logiciel de montage incruste une image
d'elle en combinaison devant une image
de l'everest
ces efforts attire l'attention des
médias locaux
impatiente d'y arriver est de hisser le
drapeau du canada je ne pense qu'à ça
mais pour hisser son drapeau sur
l'everest frias et qu'elle aura besoin d
aide
il faut trouver de bons guides une
agence de voyages qui a de bonnes
connaissances des sherpas qui vont faire
l'escaladent qui vont guider ou népal le
mont everest est la grande attraction
touristique
jouant un rôle important dans le pnb du
pays les expéditions à l'everest coûte
des dizaines de milliers de dollars
et la concurrence est vive entre les
guides et les pourvoyeurs gabriel
filippi est un alpiniste de renom et
directeur d'expédition sur l'everest
c'est courir au désastre si on prend un
peu de temps de choisir avec qui on y va
on crée des entreprises fascinant n'est
pas il n'ya pas de réglementation donc
ces compagnies là poussent comme des
champignons 1,4 kg d'engins quelques
paris et los la famille de fria à
katmandou lui recommande une entreprise
appelée atmos adventure tracking le
directeur de l'entreprise
richir hkd elle reçoit un courriel du
canada at elle parlé d'une expédition
mont everest
oui le mont everest c'est ce que je veux
on est arrivé ici hier soir on a dormi
toute la nuit
il est maintenant sept heures par
locales et on est prêt à partir
lorsque free y arrive au népal effet des
randonnée pour s'acclimater à l'altitude
entreprises ne fais pas d'histoires sur
son expérience à bethel déjà escalader
une montagne non non je pense qu'ils
n'en avaient jamais escaladé vettel déjà
marcher sur une échelle à l'horizontale
ou à la verticale n'ont jamais elle
n'avait aucune expérience de la montagne
mais comment pouviez vous attendre à ce
qu'elle intervienne ou sommet de
l'everest
je lui ai parlé et chaque fois elle
disait je peux le faire je peux le faire
il 10h ria que tant qu'un ce sera assez
déterminé il lui enseigne rond ce
qu'elle doit savoir
armé de ce conseil friaa va s'attaquer
au mont il reste après la pause
qui est responsable la compagnie qui la
guidait ou sa propre témérité
alors on y va on est prêts à marcher
pendant environ huit heures jusqu'au
deuxième arrêt pour on va prendre un
jour de repos
[Musique]
fin mars 2012 free achat est à katmandou
la capitale du népal île natale où elle
a vécu jusqu'à l'adolescence c'est ici
vous avez donc grandi ensemble oui
pendant longtemps on a passé environ
très chouette à raja est la cousine de
fria mais elles se sont toujours appelés
cher la famille ne pouvait croire que
celle qui taquinaient à cause de sa
paresse avait l'intention d'escalader
les plus hautes montagnes du monde
elle n'aimait pas marché chaque fois
qu'elle sortait de la maison elle disait
s'il te plaît appelle un taxi je suis
incapable de marcher appelle un taxi je
veux pas marché friaa finalement engagé
la compagnie locale
atmos adventures tracking qui valent à
guider au sommet de l'everest
mais at-elle fait le bon choix
atmos est une nouvelle compagnie à ce
qu'on m'a dit qu'ils avaient été créés
et n'ont jamais vu cette compagnie
assure sur la montagne
gabriel filippi a gravi cinq fois le
sommet de l'everest
il est le seul québécois et le deuxième
canadien avoir atteint le chemin par ses
deux versants pour la saison d'escaladé
de 2012
philippe y dirige sa propre expédition
depuis le camp de base
selon lui non seulement cheville a
n'avait jamais grimpé mais le choix de
la jeune compagnie atmos tu lui as été
fatidique quelqu'un qui vit à katmandou
qui a jamais été sur l'adresse est un
problème surtout si on se parle d'une
compagnie on doit aller faire le sommet
de l'everest ensemble et elle s'est
retrouvée coincée dans une compagnie qui
avait pas d'expérience
les chairs pondent avait de l'expérience
pour que la paix la montagne mais ça
prend quelqu'un pour diriger cette
équipe est
semble avoir une déficience date de ce
côté d'or friaa pourtant versé près de
40000 dollars à haute most pour la
guider
si on ajoute les coûts du voyage du
matériel et les pourboires ou sherpa et
légendaire alpinistes himalayens qui
vont l'amener jusqu'au chemin
le total frôle 80 mille dollars
au début avril free achat est en route
vers le mont everest pour une tentative
d' escalade du show mais à la mi mai il
est maintenant et elle va documenter son
journal vidéo est presque toutes les
étapes
alors on y va on est prêts à marcher
pendant environ huit heures jusqu'au 2
et marais où on va prendre un jour de
repos pour se rendre au camp de base de
l'everest des alpinistes font une
randonnée qui peut durer deux semaines
afin de s'acclimater à la rareté de
l'oxygène qui les attend sur l'everest
plus on monte en altitude - iliad
oxygène ou sommet il ya environ le tiers
de l'oxygène dans l'air qu'on respire
qu'il y en a niveau de la mer bien des
alpinistes ne pourrait y survivre c'est
pour cela qu'on appelle la partie la
plus élevée du mont everest
la zone de la mort
[Musique]
au camp de base de l'everest la saison
d'alpinisme 2012 semble mauvais augure
la situation météorologique qu'on
retrouve normalement sur des vestes fait
en sorte que les tentatives d' escalade
du show mais se limite à la fin du
printemps les en 2012 les conditions
sont encore plus difficile que
d'habitude
[Musique]
en outre on se préoccupe du grand nombre
d'alpinistes en attente au camp de base
et de l'inexpérience de certains d'entre
eux l'escaladent de l'everest est certes
très difficile mais elle n'exige pas
beaucoup de techniques d'escaladé de
haut niveau si on est assez en forme
pour continuer de mettre un pied devant
l'autre
on peut l'escaladé le journaliste
alpiniste michael godasses par
conséquent de nombreuses personnes ayant
très peu d'expérience vont à cette
montagne chaque année est de plus en
plus au fil des années
dès 9h30 par locale nous sommes au camp
de base juste au pied du mont everest
on va l'escaladé dans moins d'un mois
quand je ris achats arrivent au camp de
base à 5400 mètres d'altitude soit près
de 18 métiers son cran compense les
consolantes d'expérience parce que
personne ne pouvait ignorer que je
connais et sur la montagne cette année
en entrant sur le camp de base dans un
des premiers camps dans la droite on
vous voyait son immense affiche
et puis moi ça m'avait un peu surpris
parce que je voyais le drapeau canadien
puis j'avais pas entendu parler des
ailes au canada 20 avant de partir elle
a apporté la photo retouchée prise à
toronto
la montrant dans sa combinaison jaune
oui et elle l'a placé devant le vraiment
everest
lorsqu'on veut vendre est comme son
sirop cette expédition va être très
organisé
cette présomption dure pas longtemps
dans les séances d'entraînement comme
c'est si filmé par la caméra de son
propre casque fria et loin derrière même
dans les descentes
calais mais aux dires de tous c'est une
étudiante de bonne volonté apprécié de
ses coéquipiers et qui ne semble pas
souffrir de maux de tête ou de nous est
dû à l'altitude
etait-elle nantes l'été lente tout le
monde sait qu'elle était lente mais il
n'avait pas de maux de tête ni rien
d'autre
il continue à marcher en matière
d'organisation d'expédition à l'everest
il n'y a pas plus connu ni plus respecté
que le néo-zélandais russell bryce
pendant près de quatre décennies il a
guidé des centaines de personnes au
sommet on le surnomme le grand patron
sa compagnie moyenne expérience environ
25 clients pour l'everest en 2012 qui
ont tous versé plus de 50000 dollars
mais hrosso bryce a raison de
s'inquiéter
cette année a été très particulière
story très dangereux ou prétend la météo
inhabituelle a provoqué des avalanches
et l'effondrement de masse de glace
appelé ceyrac ce qui rend la cascade de
glace du khumbu encore plus dangereux
début mai un énorme ceyrac à des moyens
cas de haute altitude
juste avant l'arrivée prévue de dizaines
d'alpinistes d'euros sur bryce quand le
cerac s'est effondré sur le camp 3 il a
écrasé 18 30 cross six heures plus tard
ses tantes aurait était bondée il y
aurait eu convient trente deux personnes
coeur de morteau
au mieux cela signifie que la saison
d'escaladé de 2012 qui sera très
écourtée vu les pluies de la mousson
attendu en juin
le créneau d'ascension au sommet ne sera
que de deux semaines pas avant la mi mai
les accidents rang des alpinistes encore
plus nerveux il à valence détruit tout
un camp là haut
alors j'ai monté de l'équipement que des
gens ont trouvé dans la neige comme des
tentes des poils et des vivres qui
avaient été stockées au camp en somme le
contingent de toute une saison d'
escalade attanquant base des centaines
d'alpinistes prête à partir pour le
sommet à la première occasion
[Musique]
mais pour free h à une autre question se
pose quand elle vraiment sa place sur le
mont everest
on doit lui enseigner presque tous de la
pause des crampons à ses bottes à la
manière de les utiliser
or peu avant la date du départ vers le
sommet le chat pas principales dates
most change d'idée à propos de fria il
la prévient carrément de ne pas grimper
shaiya téléphone à sa cousine chouette a
raconté si vous continuez à si vous
mourez en août sûrs et tous le dit
littéralement si vous continuez vous
allez mourir et nous aussi nous vous
mourrez vous ne tuerez aussi
[Musique]
après la pause rien ne pouvait arrêter
freja ma détermination incroyable de sa
part elle devait avoir froid
[Musique]
à 19h30 le 18 mai shri achat va
entreprendre ce que personne sauf elle
ne croyait possible atteindre le sommet
de l'everest du qu'un cadre à 8000 m il
n'y a que huit cents mètres tout droit
jusqu'au toit du monde
même pour les plus aguerris l'aller
retour au sommet peut exiger de 10 à 12
heures d'efforts intenses dans l'air
appauvri en oxygène de la zone de la
mort
mais en dépit de son inexpérience fria
n'est pas parti pour le show mais
accompagné des meilleurs guides
dartmouth
le propriétaire de l'entreprise ganesh
dacoury et le sherpa le plus expérimenté
qui a prévenu chriac et ce qu'est la
mort continue vers le chemin confiant
leurs clientes les plus vulnérables à
deux sherpas moins expérimentés
même avec un supplément d'oxygène
l'ascension va être très laborieuse et
trail en rendiez 1000 m on va faire 1 1
deux ports on va faire certes 8
respiration 1 2 ponts on avance plus
recourir à ces altitudes là on est dans
un état où on est en mode survie
or fria et permis les plus lents et le
18 mai 2012
ce importe cette photo prise par un
alpiniste allemand va symboliser la
commercialisation d'une merveille
naturelle
cette que d'attentes pour monter au
sommet comme dans un parc d'attractions
je regarde cette photo je me dis est ce
qu'ils ont tous perdu la raison
la personne qui dit et il faut garder
une certaine distance entre les
grimpeurs selon le guide chevronné
russell bryce ces centaines d'alpinistes
dépendent d'une seule ligne de cordes
qui pourrait se rompre à tout moment les
précipitant sur la pente de glace une
chute de pierres
l'effondrement d'un ceyrac près tué des
dizaines de personnes et les delhaize
inévitable serait tout aussi mortelle
venir
et quand on est aussi déterminé je dois
monter au sommet et qu'il est si près et
si loin
j'entrevois que certains vont commencer
à manquer d'oxygène mais il n'y a aucun
client de loi sur bryce dans cette file
deux semaines plus tôt il a pris la
décision extraordinaire d'annuler son
expédition est informé des dizaines
d'alpinistes qui ont payé 50 mille
dollars chacun que ce serait trop
dangereux
une décision controversée sans
remboursement
il serait difficile de blâmer un élément
en particulier
tous ces éléments se sont conjugués ce
jour d'ascension au sommet ça on a fait
un jour très spécial cette année
le jour de l'ascension au sommet avec
leur lampe qui éclaire le sommet de
l'accre aide ria et s'échappe pas gremm
durant toute la soirée
à 11h30 le matin du 19 mai il grimpe
depuis 16 heures d'affilée elle doit
s'asseoir souvent pour se reposer à
plusieurs endroits le sentier qui mène
au sommet de l'everest ne plus laisser
passer qu'une seule personne
souvent on doit se résigner à avancer à
la cadence de l'alpiniste qui les
précèdent
et cela s'avère particulièrement au
dernier obstacle majeur avant le sommet
leur show et larry un mur de 15 m de
rock de glace avec une seule ligne de
code pour la montée ni descente
le 19 mai la tente dans les deux
directions et de deux heures
c'est là qu'ils se produit quelque chose
qui sera peut-être le moment capital de
la ville de fria chat rappelez-vous le
propriétaire date moss avait décidé de
se rendre au sommet on le voit ici qui
doublent friaa qui sans épuiser
par la suite de retour au sommet ils
croisent de nouveau chriac y est presque
à court de xee gènes des taux mais ils
m'ont dit il ne lui reste que 20 minutes
d'oxygène n'y aura plus d'oxygène après
cela le propriétaire ganesh dacoury dit
qu'ils savaient à ce moment qu'il était
beaucoup trop tard pour que je criais
les sherpas continue vers le sommet ils
peuvent se risquer vers le sommet
jusqu'à 14h 14h30
après c'est très dangereux il dit avoir
tenté de la convaincre de faire demi
tour evans même quand lui a dit vous ne
pouvez pas y aller
vous devez descendre avec insistance
elle a dit non j'ai payé et mon but est
d'atteindre le sommet j'y vais dans ce
cas on ne peut rien faire
l'avis de shri achat est en jeu le
propriétaire date most lui donnent une
dernière bouteille d'oxygène
puis il redescend xiahe ces deux sherpas
continuent d'attendre au monté je
comprends clients goulot mais ça ne
change rien au fait que si elle parvient
au sommet 14h30
ce sera après 19 heures d'ascension 19h
oui elle est presque déjà court
d'oxygène et elle devra redescendre dans
l'obscurité
n'est-il pas de la responsabilité de
votre compagnie de veiller à ce qu'il ne
se retrouve pas dans cette situation
[Musique]
oui
le directeur de l'expédition affirme que
du camp de base il a tout fait pour que
les sherpas face rebrousser chemin h ria
quand on cherche pas je leur ai parlé
aussi pourquoi ne l'a ramenée vous pas
pourquoi monter vous avec elle au sommet
ils m'ont dit qu'elles le radier si vous
voulez faire demi-tour vous le pouvez je
monte au sommet ils me l'ont dit comme
ça que pensez-vous de la logistique de
cet arrangement
c'est complètement les entendre c'est la
première fois que j'entends c'est
complètement ridicule
pourquoi le propriétaire au réduit lui
faire rebrousser chemin est restée avec
elle afin de veiller à ce qu'elles
rentrent match auch i can't back
voici bras et soutient que sauver des
vies c'est vraiment la seule tâche de
chef d'expédition
je sais que c'est dur j'ai dû le faire
on vit une situation extrêmement
difficile
mais plus après les choses remarquables
va se produire au sommet de l'everest
elle n'a jamais fait d'alpinisme
elle est parmi l'une en sur la montagne
sig est donc prévenu maintes fois de
rebrousser chemin
juste avant 14h30 bel après midi
shri achats réalise son rêve elle
atteint le sommet du mont everest à 8848
mètres au dessus du niveau de la mer
personne d'autre sur terre n'est alors
plus près du soleil et quelques minutes
plus tard les nouvelles seraient pas
à 5h30
je me suis réveillé et quelque chose m'a
poussé à aller à l'ordinateur
je suis allé il disait déjà que free y
avait atteint un sommet j'étais folle de
joie
je ne pouvais pas me recoucher j'ai
envoyé des courriels à tous mes amis et
à toutes ces connaissances pour leur
dire que fria avaient escaladé le mont
everest et je disais qu'il lui restait
maintenant à redescendre saine et sauve
le mari de fria bouge trop fine est
enfin souffler un peu j'étais ravi pour
elle j'étais fier pour moi ça et qu'ils
aient l'impression globale de danger que
j'avais quelles que soient mes craintes
j'ai pensé que si elle avait pu réussir
ça elle devait être aussi capable de
redescendre
[Musique]
nous voici bryce crois que même à ce
moment de triomphe cheville a déjà
dépassé le point de non retour
vous savez quelle détermination
incroyable de savoir qu'elle devait
avoir froid ou bien que dans la photo
d'elle au sommet elle ne semble pas
avoir eu froid mais elle devait avoir
froid une détermination étonnante mais
complètement stupide sans direction ni
personne pour lui dire de revenir ce
seuil
come back
sous le soleil aveuglant mais par un
temps glacial sous zéro elle savoure ce
moment pendant près d'une demi-heure
il ne semble pas y voir d'urgence même
si sa réserve d'oxygène diminue les
aurait dû savoir qu'elle n'avait presque
plus d'oxygène voulons at il mentionné
j'en ont-ils parlé ils ne me l'ont pas
dit pourquoi je ne sais pas ils ont
juste dit qu'il rentrait juste avant 15h
cheriaa les sherpas amorce le 20
décembre
[Musique]
après la pause les sherpas font tout
pour tenter de lui sauver les banques et
constamment marche masseur marche ma
soeur julie s'il te plaît mais on est
inquiet il faisait déjà nuit
[Musique]
il est près de 15 heures le 19 mai quand
free achats quitte le sommet du mont
everest pour prendre la seule direction
possible la descente je suis à g déjà
depuis vingt heures d'affilée
il ne reste que quelques heures de
clarté mais pire c'est que la météo va
se gâter
il y aura des vents presque de force
ouragans et le mercure va plonger moins
nous voici au camp 4 dans la zone de la
mort à 5900 mètres avant de huit mille
huit cents mètres plus bas au camp 4
deux autres alpinistes vont entreprendre
l'étape finale jusqu'au sommet la voix
403 leduc d'ottawa est à l'emploi du
ministère fédéral de la justice john qui
doivent ski du colorado
un docteur en géographie
environnementale à la nuit tombante junk
grave qui prend cette photo d'alpinistes
sur la montagne plus haut là d'abord
présumé qui n'ont pu il comprend qu'il
descende
après avoir passé plus d'une journée
dans la zone de la mort
dès que j'ai vu ce qui se passait j'ai
pris la photo je me suis dit que ça
n'allait pas pourquoi reste-t-il aussi
longtemps là où
alors que saint benoît le duc agent
drive qui partent vers le sommet la zone
de la mort de l'everest va s'avérer
fidèle à son nom pour sandra leduc ce
qu'il voit ensuite évoque une marque
on avait l'impression non pas de gravir
une montagne mais de voir une scène
d'horreur après une autre moins d'une
heure plus tard il voit le premier corps
n'est ministe accroché à la ligne de
cordes john que d'oise qui dit qu'il ne
pouvait pas voir s'ils vivaient encore
mais qui était évidemment trop tard
si vous pensiez que cette personne
respire est encore qu est ce que vous
auriez pu faire
y'a pas grand chose à faire on peut le
décrocher et tenter de le traîner mi mai
on va s'épuiser
il peut donc rien faire il faut être
avec d'autres pour s'occuper de cette
personne
voilà pourquoi j'ai continué de grimper
en tout ce soir-là il dit avoir
contourné trois alpinistes qui étaient
morts ou agonisants
puis il a mis fin à sa montée vers le
chemin pour aider les autres qui avaient
désespérément besoin d' aide pour
descendre plusieurs centaines de mètres
plus haut les deux sherpas pousse sans
cesse fria physiquement et verbalement
themba cher pas dit avoir utilisé le mot
népalais dj qui signifie grande soeur
disait constamment marche masseur marche
ma soeur julia s'il te plaît marche
il faisait déjà nuit il ya 7 heures
qu'ils sont partie du chemin
cela fait 27 eur consécutive d'escaladé
dans la zone de la mort de la dui 1000 m
c'est comme être dans l'espace le manque
d'oxygène et démolit corps on dit que le
corps ce mess des bories lui-même ils
accaparent tellement le plus d'énergie
qu'ils vous restent pour fonctionner
qu'il peut mal survivre plus de 20
heures
j'ai lu des commentaires du genre
les sherpas peuvent vous attacher sur
leur dos et vous transporter et c'est
complètement faux je défie tous ceux qui
disent ça d'aller à l'everest et de voir
par eux-mêmes
pour
riel et sherpa croise alors la vague
suivante d'alpinistes en route vers le
sommet shia implore l'aide des grimpeurs
les supplie de ne pas la laisser mourir
ses sherpas bord de l'épuisement eux
aussi s'efforce de la maintenir debout
elle ne pouvait rester debout que si
nous la soutenions tous les deux c'est
juste un moment si elle avait bouger les
jambes serait tombé comme si elle était
paralysée
rappelez-vous free a reçu sa dernière
bouteille d'oxygène aux ressources et la
rue quelques heures plus tôt combien de
temps cet oxygène a laissé durer quatre
heures probablement selon le guide on
lui avait donné assez d'oxygène pour
l'ascension mais pas pour la descente
on en avait donc lui elle est revenue à
la base d'urée sauvé louis puis j'en
déduis qu'elle a probablement dû faire
le trajet du sommet sud au balcon sans
oxygène
selon les sherpas il était passé 22h15
fria à 16 bouger et de parler perché sur
la cornée chapelet le bail qu'on a
quelque 8400 mètres d'altitude
il accroche la ligne de cordes il laisse
là parmi les centaines d'autres
alpinistes de l'everest dont les corps
gelés sont restés dans la zone de la
mort
[Musique]
peu après un autre cher pas appeler un
badge en bout qui monte aperçoit une
personne qui de toute évidence a besoin
d' aide et elle portait une combinaison
de duvet avec le drapeau canadien rouge
et blanc le dessin est rouge et blanc du
drapeau
oui vous avez reconnu drapeau canadien
oui même bas reconnaît la femme dont il
a vu la faute au camp de base la
canadienne et au népal
il utilise lui aussi le mot népalais qui
signifie grande soeur je les appelais
comme un népalais je lui ai dit diddy
diddy 3 ou 4 au soir puis de manière
soudaine inattendue chez ea semble
vouloir dire quelque chose
l'ex elle a fait comment elles sont le
genre
elle a parlé pas parler juste un sens il
dit qu'il a tenté de la ranimer mais
qu'il était trop tard j'ai sorti l'eau
et l'oxygène
je les appelais quatre fois mais elle ne
m'a pas répondu
response mais quand il comprend que
cheyenne respire plus bemba prend cette
photo puis il part à la recherche
d'autres alpinistes mal en point ce soir
l'homme il sombre c'est là qu'on voit
souvent les équipes de 4 5 personnes qui
doivent être composées pour descendre
une seule personne
c'est complexe dans la journée
dont on parle du 19 mai tout le monde
était occupée à monter sa propre équipe
vers le sommet donc il y avait pas
vraiment de jeunes disponibles tout le
monde j'ai erré chacun sa propre
situation à cause du trafic qui était
présent sur la montagne cette journée-là
lent mais par radio les sherpas de
chiyah annonce l'horrible nouvelle au
camp base chouette à la cousine de fria
style avant d'apprendre qu'on avait vu
son corps on espérait qu'elle soit
toujours vivante était so as to
il m'a dit que c'était pas possible que
ses vêtements étaient d'une autre
couleur que ceux des autres alpinistes
il y avait aussi le drapeau canadien
c'était donc le sien
le corps de fria reste dix jours à plus
de 8000 mètres jusqu'à ce qu'une équipe
de secours parviennent à la zone de la
mort ils redescendent
qui n'est pas l'ennemie la cheville à
charbonnages
je suis achat est incinéré à katmandou
selon la tradition et d'où son mari
allume le bûcher funéraire rousseau
maintenant accepter que sa femme soit
aller chercher quelque chose où il reste
si elle accomplissait slave ça
changerait sa perception delman à elles
auraient toujours ce point d'ancrage en
elle et ses normes de cette touche tout
le monde
en fin de compte il sait que cette fin
des plus terribles résulte en grande
partie de ce qu'il y avait de meilleurs
chiffres ia
[Musique]
c'est incroyable quand je repense à elle
en me disant qu'il voulait faire la fête
je suis abasourdi comment ne pas l'être
je n'aurais jamais pensé que c'était
possible mais j'en suis venu à respecter
sa détermination et je savais qu'elle
était bien fait
j'suis achat et l un des dix alpinistes
qui ne sont pas descendus vivant du mont
everest cette saison au troisième rang
des pires de l'histoire et cela soulève
des questions fondamentales si
l'embouteillage du 18 mai a contribué à
ce carnage comment peut-on éviter que
cela ne se reproduise
devrait-on limiter le nombre d'un
ministre sur l'everest
devrait-on carrément refusé d'accepter
des novices comme fria
dans ce pays où le lait pas les moyens
gagnent moins de 500 dollars par année
le mont everest engendre des revenus
annuels de près de 100 millions de
dollars
les dirigeants du gouvernement ont
néanmoins dit ne pas pouvoir répondre à
nos questions parce qu'ils ne s'y sont
pas intéressés avant sonné par le
tourisme c'est leur revenu numéro un et
se couper des milliers de dollars que ça
représente avoir des gens sur l'everest
pour eux on n'y touche pas le grand
patron de l'everest qui a annulé son
expédition cette année croit que toutes
les entreprises de l'everest doivent
prioriser les vies sauvées plutôt que
l'atteinte du chemin
le problème c'est notamment qu'au fil
des années on a eu trop de réussite ça
semble presque automatique d'atteindre
le sommet de la montagne
mais c'est faux elle peut se retourner
contre vous et vous mordre et c'est ce
qu'elle a fait cette injection
[Musique]
quant à saint benoît le duc et john kerr
grave qui quelques jours après leur
expérience de vie et de mort sur
l'everest
ils accomplissent quelque chose de
remarquable lui aussi ils remontent
ensemble dans la zone de la mort et
cette fois ils reviennent ou chômé lors
de l'ascension et de la descente il
croise free h à la première fois qu'il
fit monter là-haut et que j'ai vu le
drapeau canadien
je me suis sentie malade et quand je
suis redescendu j'avais envie de pleurer
je n'avais pas fait bien
je ne savais rien d'elle alors mais je
pensais aux siens à sa famille alors que
call of
parce que si ça avait été moi
je sais ce que ma famille aurait
ressenti c'était difficile parce que
c'était une vraie personne avec des gens
qu'il aimait il allait devoir composer
avec ça pour le reste de leur vie
[Musique]
plusieurs questions avant de terminer
quel est le legs de shri h à ce qu'elle
a vécu vaz et changer quelque chose au
moins brest où il y aura-t-il encore de
nombreux cas du genre de même atteint
une personne sans emploi cap man nouveau
s'installe une affiche et ils vont
recruter des gens depuis va partir sa
compagnie moi je pense que c'est
peut-être là que le gouvernement
népalais pour jouer un rôle
c'est à dire que tous ceux qui veulent
faire des treks qui veulent faire des
ascensions sur les vrais sous ailleurs
sur notre montagne devrait avoir un
certain bailliage en arrière il devrait
rencontrer certains critères parce que
nous on peut faire devoir de dire je
prends pas cette personne là mais si la
porte est ouverte pour d'autres de dire
mon jeune prend on verse avec le
problème
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine enquête nous
suivons la trace de pierre poutine et
levons le voile sur l'une des plus
grosses atteinte à la démocratie au
canada les appels trompeur les robes aux
cols
ça aurait pu aider
élections canada sauf que l'information
n'était pas correct c'est l'attaqué la
plus directe à notre démocratie
merci d'avoir été là
bonsoir la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
nous